[Musik]
ich frage sie herr abgeordneter scholz
nehmen sie die wahl an
das war laut und vernehmlich herr
bundeskanzler
ich gratuliere ihnen am des ganzen
hauses zu ihrer wahl nach der wahl im
bundestag ging es für olaf scholz weiter
ins schloss bellevue dort wurde er
offiziell von bundespräsident steinmeier
zum bundeskanzler anderen verliebt seine
vorgängerin verabschiedete er am
nachmittag im kanzleramt vor angela
merkel gab es einen blumenstrauß und
viel applaus
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
der machtwechsel ist vollzogen
deutschland hat eine neue regierung
die ära merkel endet heute nach 16
jahren was wird jetzt anders welche
ziele hat sich das historisch erste
bündnis von spd grünen und fdp auf
bundesebene
gesetzt das schauen wir uns in dieser
sendung genauer an gleich dann auch ein
ausführliches interview mit dem frisch
gewählten bundeskanzler was nun herr
scholz zunächst aber einen blick auf die
drängendsten themen und aufgaben der
neuen regierung die das ruder in
unruhiger zeit übernimmt bernd nicht
fasst das zusammen
die korona pandemie sie bleibt die
aktuell größte herausforderung im land
sie ist so groß dass sie die ampel
koalition ihrer noch vor ihrem
amtsantritt zum handeln zwingt
trotz steigender infektionszahlen
erklären sie erst das ende der
epidemischen notlage dann verschärfen
sie das infektionsschutzgesetz
korrigieren es um es wenig später noch
einmal zu verschärfen
ein fehlstart für scholz und co
sie haben den wissenschaftlern das forum
gegeben
und haben sich zurückgezogen
und war sprachlos wie so ein vakuum habe
ich dem kunden in bezug auf krone hätte
ich mir gewünscht dass herr scholz mehr
empathie gezeigt hätte jetzt also ein
quasi lockdown für ungeimpfte
die impfpflicht kommt erst für bestimmte
gruppen bald wohl eine allgemeine aber
wie sehr spaltet das alles die
gesellschaft
und dem pflicht halte ich die aktuellen
überlegungen für sinnvoll dass man
darüber nachdenkt weil die spaltung in
der gesellschaft die haben wir schon es
gibt einfach eine laute minderheit ich
finde das ist schlimm dass jetzt so
diese spaltung geht geimpft nicht geben
man müsste mir haben die eigene
verantwortung der leute appellieren
die zweite riesige herausforderung der
klimaschutz eine so heißt es oft
jahrhundertaufgabe scholz und die ampel
haben ehrgeizige ziele formuliert so
soll der anteil regenerativer energien
am strombedarf auf 80 prozent bis 2030
steigen deutschland industrieproduktion
klimaneutral werden also ich glaube dass
das nicht zu schaffen ist ich glaube man
kann viel ausbauen gerade wenn man bei
baurecht zum beispiel vereinfacht wenn
man eben offshore wind stärker ausbauen
das geht schon ich persönlich wünsche
mir sehr dass die deutsche bahn viel
preiswerter wird und dafür die
kerosinsteuer deutlich ansteigt all das
kostet geld und so wird die
finanzpolitik zur dritten
riesenherausforderung
2022 werden scholz und kurvigen kroner
noch einmal an die 100 milliarden euro
neue schulden aufnehmen erst 2023 soll
die im grundgesetz verankerte
schuldenbremse wieder greifen
ich habe selber kinder also am ende wird
es auf der nächsten generation lasten
wie man die schulden dann irgendwann
wieder ab weil einfach streichen kann
man sie ja nicht und dann ist da noch
die neue kriegsangst im osten europas
der russische truppenaufmarsch an der
grenze zur ukraine
er zwingt die neue bundesregierung dazu
sich zu positionieren
zum beispiel bei der umstrittenen erdgas
leitung nord stream 2 sie sind also
gleich mehrfach gewaltig gefordert der
neue kanzler und seine ampel partner
der ehrgeiz zu gestalten und nicht nur
zu reagieren ist der ampel regierung
anzumerken daran knüpfen sich viele
fragen und die haben bettina schausten
und peter frey dem heute gewählten
kanzler vor etwa zwei stunden gestellt
was nun herr scholz
was nun herr scholz was nun herr
bundeskanzler
sie haben jahrelang und zielbewusst auf
diesen heutigen tag hingearbeitet trotz
schlechter umfragen für die spd und
trotz mancher auch persönliche
enttäuschung zb beim spd parteivorsitz
ihr umfeld war immer unerschütterlich
optimistisch gab es bei ihnen dem moment
wo sie dachten dass wird nichts mehr
ich habe es immer für möglich gehalten
dass die spd die regierung dieses landes
anführt und habe immer gedacht dass dazu
ein paar voraussetzungen gegeben sein
müssen eine geschlossene partei ein
klares bekenntnis zum kandidaten und
dann natürlich eine vorstellung davon
wie es weitergehen soll in unserer
gesellschaft die wir das sicherstellen
können dass in zehn 20 30 jahren noch
gute arbeitsplätze da sind dass wir die
industrielle modernisierung hinbekommen
die uns zugleich in die lage versetzt
den klimawandel aufzuhalten und dass wir
es schaffen mehr respekt in dieser
gesellschaft zu schaffen darüber haben
wir gesprochen und daraus haben wir
jetzt den auftrag bekommen nun sind sie
es also deutscher bundeskanzler der
neunte und der vierte
sozialdemokratische und sie ziehen ja
selbst schon parallelen haben zum
beispiel auf 1969 verwiesen als willy
brandt kanzler wurde empfinden sie die
aufgabe die jetzt auf sie zukommt selbst
so groß so historisch auch beginnt jetzt
so was wie eine epoche olaf scholz es
beginnt jedenfalls an epoche die diese
20er jahre ausmachen die gerade beginnen
denn denen es eben um die aufgaben geht
dich eben beschrieben habe wenn wir das
hinkriegen wollen mit der industriellen
modernisierung müssen wir die
stromerzeugung aus erneuerbaren
energiequellen aus windkraft aus so
leitner geht massiv ausbauen das ist
schon etwas das ganz ganz zentrales wir
müssen die digitalisierung voranbringen
da wird viel gemacht werden müssen und
wenn wir für mehr respekt in der
gesellschaft sorgen für ein mindestlohn
für stabile renten dann sind das auch
entscheidungen die das zusammenleben und
den zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft
stärker machen die überschrift über die
koalition die sie heute auch gewählt hat
im bundestag heißt fortschritt aber
schulz was bedeutet fortschritt für sie
so wie früher mehr technik in allen
lebenslagen
wirtschaftswachstum 24 oder am liebsten
5% oder heißt fortschritt für sie auch
nachhaltiger seien sparsamer seien auch
bescheidener sein
stehen ja gerade an einer zeitenwende in
der das eine und das andere mehr oder
weniger miteinander verbunden sein kann
also technologischer fortschritt auch
ökonomischer fortschritt der es uns
möglich macht ein starkes
wirtschaftliches wachstum zu haben und
global wettbewerbsfähig zu sein und
gleichzeitig eben die aufgabe
hinzubekommen den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufzuhalten
das ist also kein gegensatz und deshalb
ist das hier auch eine ganz besondere
fortschritts koalition weil sie sich in
diesem verständnis finden kann aber
wirtschaftswachstum muss weiter seien
grenzen des wachstums bedeutet nicht
weniger oder nullwachstum es geht darum
den ressourcenverbrauch zu reduzieren
und die klima emissionen zb zu
beseitigen sodass wie klimaneutral
wirtschaften können aber das wird
natürlich trotzdem ein besseres leben
ermöglichen ein besseres als uns heute
vorstellen können auch durch den
technologen ich hoffe dass noch gar
nicht recht glauben dass das klappen
kann es ist jedenfalls eine mammut
aufgabe in dieser dreier konstellation
die erste ampel auf bundesebene und sie
müssen ja im grunde dieser beiden pole
fdp und grünen auch ein bisschen
zusammen bringen beide robert habeck und
christian lindner haben schon gesagt sie
wollen die koalition durchaus prägen wie
soll das funktionieren
wie ist ihre rolle dabei werden sie
moderator sein oder werden sie sich
jeweils auf eine seite schlagen es geht
um einen aufbruch und dass alle drei
parteien sich fortschritt für unsere
gesellschaft vorstellen nicht komplett
identisch aber doch mit einer großen
schnittmenge das ist die grundlage dafür
dass da auch was gelingen kann das über
vier jahre hinaus reicht und wenn ich
mich noch einmal zurück erinnere an die
verhandlungen die wir über die bildung
der regierung geführt haben dann kann
ich daraus nur den schluss ziehen dass
wird sogar gelegen das ist relativ
harmonisch gewesen auch an den punkt wo
es unterschiedliche ausgangspunkt even
the rain und es gibt auch die
möglichkeit dass nach vorne hin zu guten
lösungen zu bringen und das habe ich
versucht schon während der
koalitionsverhandlungen
das soll mir auch gelingen also sieht in
der region aber sie wollen ja auch
macher sein passt das zusammen natürlich
es geht ja was das was wir voranbringen
wollen und ein paar punkte haben wir
schon besprochen und nicht genannt die
wollen wir auch real umsätzen ich nehme
mal so ein thema auf das viele bürger
und bürger jetzt umtreibt den
wohnungsbau 400.000 euro pro jahr sind
was ganz reales bezahlbare wohnung auch
und natürlich gilt das auch für die
vielen aufgaben die wir uns gestellt
haben in dem miteinander unserer
gesellschaft da ist ja vieles was unser
land noch ein bisschen offener und
liberaler machen könnte liegen geblieben
wegen konservativer zweifel und bedenken
das kann jetzt zu einem guten ergebnis
nach vorne geführt werden die
konservativen zwei fechter ist noch kurz
fragen darf die bringt jetzt die fdp
wird das klappen zwischen grünen und fdp
das wird klappen das wird auch klappen
zwischen allen drei parteien und ich
glaube dass es nicht richtig wäre zu
sagen da sind zwei die sich streiten und
dann so auch die spd dafür dass es einen
konsens gibt sondern es geht ja darum
dass in der sache gut aufzulösen und wir
haben ja auch unserer eigenen
vorstellungen davon was zu tun ist und
noch mal wenn man sich an die atmosphäre
der verhandlungen zurück erinnert aber
auch das gefühl dass heute alle hatten
als sie ihre ernennung als minister und
ministern vom bundespräsidenten bekommen
haben dann ist das schon etwas wo die
vertrauensbasis existiert die für so was
notwendig ist und vertrauen geht es auch
noch stolz wenn sie ihre erste
auslandsreise machen nach paris am
freitag sie werden präsident mark
treffen er steht von der schwierigen
wiederwahl und er hat ein bisschen
skepsis gegenüber der neuen deutschen
regierung oder vor allem gegenüber dem
neuen deutschen finanzminister christian
lindner wird er mit einer restriktiven
finanzpolitik die rolle als zuchtmeister
europas fortsetzen oder werden sie sagen
dass übernehme ich
die künftige regierung hat sich
verständigt wie wir die großen
herausforderungen die für europa stehen
lösen wollen und dazu gehört dass wir
natürlich unsere verantwortung für den
erfolg des ganzen europas anerkennen wie
wir das mit dem wiederaufbau programm
bereits gemacht haben als deutsche
regierung in europa und darüber hinaus
und auch mit noch mehr gemeinsame
schulden oder jedenfalls der möglichkeit
sie zu machen es geht doch jetzt erstmal
darum dieses programm umzusetzen da sind
ja noch fast keine mittel ausgegeben und
das ist eines für viele viele jahre was
wir brauchen ist ausreichende
flexibilität wie sie sich im rahmen des
stabilitäts und wachstumspaktes in
europa ja auch jetzt als möglicher
erwiesen hat wie sie haben eine ganze
krise bekämpft mit diesen rahmen warum
soll der nicht auch für die zukunft
reichen sie haben darauf hingewiesen
klimaneutrale wirtschaft schreiben sie
sich auf die fahnen während damit ja
auch ein vorbild in europa jetzt haben
sie dann die sense mit makro der
zeichnet sich jedenfalls ab denn der
hält ja für diesen umbau atomkraft als
sozusagen grüne energiequelle für
notwendig angela merkel hat dem immer
entschieden widersprochen werden sie das
auch tun wir gehen unseren weg und ich
glaube dass das auch einer ist für den
wir gute gründe haben dass andere länder
die frage wie sie den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufhalten wollen anders
beantworten werden wir ja nicht
aufhalten können wir können nur
das beitragen was wir in deutschland zu
leisten vermögen unsere ingenieure und
ingenieure unser unternehmen unsere
wissenschaft und wir glauben dass wir es
hinbekommen können mit einem massiven
ausbau der produktion von strom aus
erneuerbaren energien nicht nur umso
stromverbräuche anders zu organisieren
sondern auch industrielle prozesse neu
aufzustellen so dass das klimaneutral
möglich ist und das wird dann natürlich
wenn das funktioniert und wenn die
globale wettbewerbsfähigkeit deutschland
darüber bewiesen ist von vielen
nachgemacht haben aber immer krank
könnte ihnen hier am freitag aussagen
solange die deutsche energieversorgung
nicht komplett grün geworden ist und
nachhaltig werdet ihr weiter und so eine
art ob strom importieren erst mal bauen
wir die energieerzeugung und deutschland
aus das ist doch auch einer der
fortschritte die schon mit der
regierungsbildung verbunden sind
jahrelang ist bestritten worden von
weiten teilen der politik dass wir einen
höheren strombedarf haben obwohl die
ganze chemie-industrie uns mitgeteilt
hat sie braucht 2040 50 ungefähr so viel
strom wie deutschland insgesamt heute
das gleiche ähnliches kann man für die
stahlindustrie für den maschinenbau für
die automobilen sein letzter punkt sein
herr bundeskanzler wo deutschland diese
importe von atomstrom aus anderen
ländern nicht mehr braucht wir haben
jetzt die grundlagen dafür gelegt dass
wir die erzeugung ausbauen können und
zum beispiel werden sie erfinden dass
wir jahrelange streitereien beenden
werden über die beschleunigung von
planungsverfahren über schnelle
genehmigung wie wir das hinkriegen dass
so was auch gelingt da soll deutschland
wirklich einen richtigen aufbruch
hinkriegen und dann wird der fortschritt
möglich bleibt ein wagnis aber eines bei
dem ganz viele bürgern und bürger
mitgehen werden weil sie sagen es geht
auch für mich in meinem ganz
persönlichen leben mit meinem beruf
unmittelbar gut aus wo die vermutlich
nicht gehen mit gehen werden ist in der
lausitz kohleausstieg 2038 war
vereinbart der soll wie es im
koalitionsvertrag heißt idealerweise
vorgezogen werden vielleicht schon 20 30
und dort wirft man ihn wortbruch vor sie
hätten vor ort cottbus in der region das
versprechen gegeben und nun könne man
sich nicht auf sie verlassen oder
wiederholen sie das versprechen 20 38
darauf kann man sich in der lausitz
verlassen wir bleiben in dem rahmen den
wir
in den letzten jahren
festgelegt haben und dazu gehört
natürlich die ganze zeit der massive
ausbau der erneuerbaren energiequellen
als produktions möglichkeit für strom
als voraussetzung dafür dass wir auch
zügiger aus der kohleverstromung
aussteigen können als das bisher geplant
ist diese aufgabe jetzt anzupacken das
ist die zentrale herausforderung vor der
wir unmittelbar stehen und da glaube ich
gehen viele mit weil wir ja auch ein
ganz konkretes sind planen für die
zukunft derjenigen regionen in
deutschland damit verbinden der die
bisher für die stromversorgung in
deutschland so eine wichtige rolle
gespielt haben neue kraftwerke übrigens
auch neue gaskraftwerke in diesen
regionen langfristig die nutzung von
wasserstoff die nutzung alter zeugung
infrastrukturen die damit verbunden sind
auch neue arbeitsplätze
das wird überall passiert versprechen
lautet jetzt wir werden euch nicht
überfordern menschen und kommunen aber
ohne jahreszahl das was wir doch die
ganze zeit
hinkriegen müssen ist das nicht mehr
abstrakt gesprochen wird sondern konkret
gehandelt wird und die konkrete handlung
ist im nächsten jahr schon die
beschleunigung aller genehmigungs und
planungsverfahren die erhöhung der
ausbauziele schon bis 2030 da haben wir
schon viele leute öffentlich zugegeben
dass die bisherigen planung nicht
gestimmt haben ich habe darüber jahre
lang geredet und jetzt sorgen wir dafür
dass wir mehr stromerzeugung in
deutschland gekommen sie sagen viele
gehen mit sie versuchen die bürger
mitzunehmen und die bürgerinnen herr
scholz aber sie wissen auch dass die
glaubwürdigkeit der politik in den
letzten monaten sehr gelitten hat nicht
nur bei dem thema energie lausitz
sondern auch beim thema corona und
impfpflicht gerade im osten baut sich da
was auf und das spüren sie wie sehr
belastet es den start ihrer regierung
dass sie das versprechen es wird keine
impfpflicht geben einkassieren müssen
viele sagen ja das beginnt jetzt alles
mit einem wortbruch
die meisten bürgern bürger sind sehr
besorgt über die möglichen folgen der
korona pandemie für ihre gesundheit die
allermeisten bürgern bürger haben sich
impfen lassen
und wir wissen dass das gegenwärtige
infektionsgeschehen voran daher rührt
dass es zwar sehr viele gibt die sich
impfen lassen haben aber auch im
internationalen vergleich nicht genug
wären wir weiter vorangekommen würden
wir heute nicht sorge haben müssen dass
es probleme geben könnte im hinblick auf
die kapazitäten der intensivstation
unserer krankenhäuser und deshalb ist es
doch nur richtig zu sagen wir sind nicht
so weit gekommen wie wir gehofft haben
im hinblick auf die überzeugung
ausreichend vieler bürgerinnen und
bürger von der impfung und da muss dann
ein neuer schub rein und das verbindet
sich mit der großen impfkampagne die wir
jetzt auf den weg gebracht haben damit
dass jetzt ein krisenstab im kanzleramt
eingerichtet dass general breuer den
leitet und das jetzt millionenfach noch
bis weihnachten noch dieses jahr
zustande zu kriegen und gleichzeitig
dann natürlich die debatte wie kriegen
wir noch mehr überzeugt und noch mehr
dazu gebracht dass sie sich auch impfen
lassen weil das für uns alle und unser
aller gesundheit wichtig ist und haben
sich schon zurückgewiesen den vorwurf
dass sie während der
koalitionsverhandlungen im grunde die
brisanz der lage zu spät erkannt haben
vielleicht sich auch zu sehr
konzentriert haben auf klimaschutz und
andere dinge dass weisen sie ja zurück
aber im rückblick mal gesehen bedauern
sie im grunde dass sie nicht später
nicht früher angesprungen sind dass sie
vielleicht auch eben dieses versprechen
soll keine impfpflicht geben
ausgesprochen haben aus meiner sicht
sind jetzt viele viele sehr weit
reichende maßnahmen ergriffen worden die
wir zum beispiel vor einem jahr gar
nicht ergreifen konnten also wenn wir
jetzt darüber reden dass es für den
zutritt zu restaurants zu
handelsgeschäften zu kulturellen
veranstaltungen zu kinos die
voraussetzung ist dass man geimpft ist
ein ausreichender impfschutz hat oder
aber von einer infektion genesen ist
wenn wir manchmal noch zusätzlich die
voraussetzung schaffen dass man sich
auch noch tagesaktuell hat testen lassen
dann sind das ja handlungsmöglichkeiten
die hatten wir vor einem jahr nicht wir
haben zusätzlich dafür gesorgt dass es
so ist dass im öffentlichen verkehr auch
eine solche regelung gilt dass man da
geimpft genese oder getestet sein kann
wir haben das für die arbeitsplätze
gemacht wir haben jetzt entscheidung
getroffen hinblick auf das impfen von
beschäftigten trotz der scholz eine
richtung wo das kleinere gruppen sind
also altenpflege einrichtungen und
krankenhäuser und aus meiner sicht ist
das schon ziemlich massiv was jetzt auf
den weg gebracht worden ist ich bin sehr
froh dass es auch gelungen ist eine
verständigung mit den 16 ländern
herbeizuführen und wie gesagt dass wir
diesen krisenstab trotzdem ist heute der
tag herr scholz mit den meisten corona
toten seit februar wie viel geht da
davon auf die kappe der politik die nach
dem wahlkampf in der phase
oktober/november vielleicht schon
september zu unentschlossen gehandelt
hat ich bin überzeugt dass wir vor allem
eine große entschlossenheit brauchen
jetzt das mit dem impfen hinzukriegen
und das will ich noch mal sagen das ist
ja etwas was wir als bürgerinnen und
bürger nur gemeinsam zustande kriegen
auch sie und die medien genauso wie
diejenigen der politik verantwortung
haben müssen darüber nicht nur
achselzucken treten so als beobachter
beobachtet und wir sollten uns als
bürgern und bürger auch ganz aktiv daran
beteiligen zu sagen leute gebt euch
eindruck es ist für euch selber für eure
liebsten und für die gesamte
gesellschaft wichtig ist und deshalb
nutze ich jede gelegenheit das zu sagen
lasst euch impfen besorgt durch eine
blutung sie sind der bundeskanzler aller
deutschen sind sie auch der
bundeskanzler der impfgegner auch der
die auf die straße gehen mit protest
wenn ident klar ich bin bundeskanzler
aller deutschen so verstehe ich mich und
dazu gehört aber auch dass ich klar wenn
in dem was ich richtig finde und das
sage glaubt dass steht dann auch allen
deutschen zu dass ich in so einer
existenziellen frage nicht
schwierig bleibe sondern sage wirklich
es geht darum dass sich alle impfen
lassen und die diskussion müsse geführt
werden ich will ja auch vor allem
zuallererst überzeugen und ich finde
auch dass man keinen falschen eindruck
erwecken darf wenn die allermeisten
bürgerinnen und bürger geimpft sind
viele sich jetzt booster impfung holen
wenn viele die gar nicht gegen das
impfen sind sondern nur nicht dazu
gekommen sind das jetzt machen weil alle
merken da ist was los dann kann man ja
nicht von einer gespaltenen gesellschaft
reden wir dass einige tun aber man muss
trotzdem diese kontroversen debatten
auch führen und sagen
warum wir das anders sehen und musste
ich begründen und dazu bin ich gerne was
sie versuchen jetzt zu motivieren und
mit zunehmender scholz aber gleichzeitig
ist in sachsen etwas groß mit den
protesten vor den wohnhäusern der
politiker sie haben das schon scharf
verurteilt aber die frage ist können sie
etwas gegen die plattform tun die den
impfgegnern dazu dient sich zu
verabreden zu kommunizieren telegramm
kann ihre neue innenminister an dieser
stelle wirkungsvoll das instrument den
impfgegnern
impfgegnern aus der hand schlagen das am
ende dazu dient eben auch gewalt in
unserer gesellschaft zu bringen wir
haben wir bereits gesetze auf den weg
gebracht gegen hass und hetze im netz
das wird auch für die zukunft wichtig
bleiben und eine aufgabe an der man
arbeiten muss ich will ausdrücklich
sagen es geht darum dass man hass und
hetze bekämpft
akzeptabel muss sein dass den bürgern
und bürger unterschiedliche meinungen
haben diese auch entschieden vortragen
aber es geht ja darum dass wir
verhindern dass eine aggression
produziert wird die sich dann auch gegen
sachen oder personen richtet und ich
will das hier nochmal aufgreifen was sie
angesprochen haben fackel umzüge vor dem
privat wohnhaus einer
gesundheitsministerin sind wirklich eine
dramatische grenzüberschreitung da
müssen wir als demokraten demokraten
sagen wir lassen solche
einschüchterungsversuche nicht zu
herr bundeskanzler zu unserer sendung
gehört die satz ergänzung sie kennen das
wir geben einen halbsatz vor und sie
ergänzen ihnen möglichst kurz der erste
halbsatz lautet dass mir heute
mindestens 15 stimmen aus der
ampelkoalition gefehlt haben
ist ein fakt ich bin mit satter mehrheit
gewählt worden und es sind auch im
übrigen wahlen und der korona
bedingungen da sind ja auch viele krank
für meine kanzlerschaft hat mir angela
merkel mit auf den weg gegeben
glückwünsche und
dass sie weiter so vertrauensvoll mit
mir zusammenarbeitet wie wir das in den
letzten jahren aber auch gerade in den
letzten wochen seit der bundestagswahl
getan habe und wir werden uns auch
weiter austauschen auch über politik
meinen schärfsten kritiker kevin köhler
zum spd-generalsekretär zu machen da ist
ja gar kein kritiker sondern der
künftigen als sekretär der spd jetzt
kein jetzt keine kritiker mehr dass wir
bis weihnachten wirklich 30 millionen
booster impfungen schaffen es sind noch
16 tage es ist eine ganz ehrgeizige
aufgabe aber überall im land sich neue
impfzentren entstehen viele die sich
mühe geben und wir versuchen wir auch
all die probleme die offenkundig
geworden sind in der logistik in der
versorgung in der beschaffung
aufzulösen und uns da hinterher zu
begeben
hoffentlich werden wir keine
unüberwindbaren hürden entdecken aber am
ende haben wir uns erstmal dran gemacht
auch wirklich ins detail zu gehen und
deshalb das sollte schon unser ehrgeiz
sein dass milch alter affären stichwort
wirecard auch als kanzler noch verfolgen
glaube ich nicht es wird überall
gesprochen was man so getan hat in
meinem langen politischen leben in dem
fall ist es ja auch klargestellt worden
dass hier sehr entschieden gehandelt
worden ist das recht neu zu organisieren
und ich bin sehr stolz auf das was wir
da unternommen haben dass kein deutscher
regierungsvertreter zu den olympischen
spielen nach china fahren sollte
ist eine debatte die jetzt ganz
aufgeregt begonnen hat ich finde man
muss sich sorgfältig beraten was
passiert es geht bei dem sport um eine
großartige sache die ja seit olympia
historische und antiken traditionen
eigentlich zum miteinander miteinander
streit wird das ändert ja bis 1936 und
dem was hitler in deutschland
veranstaltet hat ja aber es ist auch
erstmal so dass wir diesen gedanken gibt
es nicht beiseite packen sollten der mit
olympia verbunden ist und was das
konkret bedeutet das wird man im rahmen
und internationalen verbunden mit
anderen besprechen müssen ich jedenfalls
finde dass es keinen anlass gibt hier
vorschnell sich auf irgendeinem vorgehen
hin zu befüllen vorschnell die usa haben
sich bereits entschieden australien
schließt sich an sie werden jetzt nicht
der erste der einen diplomatischen weg
hat an glaube dass es trotzdem richtig
sorgfältig zu überlegen was man tut in
der politik auch in der internationalen
politik ist nationales handeln ganz ganz
entscheidend für frieden und sicher das
klingt jetzt ein bisschen so herr scholz
als würden sie weiter vor allem der
kanzler der exportnation sein die die
wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit china nicht
aufs spiel setzen will und weniger der
humanitäre außenpolitik macht wie ihre
außenministerin wenn das ein gegensatz
wäre was sie da beschreiben dann wäre
das ein interessantes thema ist es aber
glaube ich nur wenn man das so fragt das
bleibt in der realität gar kein thema
das wirklich weiter führt will ich ihnen
auch sehr konkret sagen
was haben
männer wie willy brandt und helmut
schmidt auf den weg gebracht als sie die
ostpolitik und die entspannungs politik
entwickelt haben dass es möglich ist ein
miteinander zu entwickeln in einer
dramatisch verfeindeten situation die
auch für den frieden und die sicherheit
sehr bedrohlich wahr heute wissen wir
dass der eiserne vorhang verschwunden
ist dass die demokratie empfehlen der
kommunistischen diktaturen in europa
heute die realität ausmacht dass wir in
der europäischen union verbunden sind
miteinander hat also gewirkt und was
mussten dafür dinge verstanden werden
und trotzdem waren jan brandt und
schmidt nicht leute die nur an
wirtschaftlichen fragen interessiert
wann sie haben damit einen großen
beitrag geleistet und gemeinsam
sicherheit zu organisieren in einer welt
die ganz anders sein wird schon in zehn
20 30 jahren als heute das ist die große
aufgabe da wird es zehn milliarden
bürgern und bürger auf der welt geben da
wird es nicht nur russland und die usa
sondern auch china und korea und japan
und vietnam und indonesien und malaysia
und indien und sicher auch nationen aus
afrika und im süden amerikas geben die
bedeutung haben für uns muss die
konsequenz sein selber stark zu sein für
uns muss die konsequenz sein verbunden
sein mit denjenigen die mit uns teilen
dass wir demokratien und rechtsstaaten
sind wie die usa zum beispiel und für
uns muss die konsequenz sein dass wir
unsere meinung und unsere haltung in
dieser frage sehr klar vertreten aber
auch wissen dass ein miteinander in der
welt stattfinden muss auch mit regierung
die ganz an unsere was heißt dass dieses
starke plädoyer
herr bundeskanzler für das verhältnis zu
russland also ein land das truppen an
der grenze zur ukraine aufmarschieren
lässt sehen sie denn jetzt wenn man
ihnen so folgt den ausführungen chancen
zu einem neustart im verhältnis russland
was hilft gegen putins aggressiven kurs
am ende dann doch nur härte es muss
klarheit existieren über das was für uns
außer frage steht und außer frage steht
der große fortschritt der verständigung
die seit den 70er jahren in europa
gelungen sind nämlich dass wir
gemeinsame sicherheit nur erreichen und
erhalten können wenn die grenzen und
verletzt nicht bleiben wenn niemand in
geschichtsbüchern welt wie diesmal vor
200 300 400 jahren war sondern sagt die
grenzen die wir heute haben werden nicht
in frage gestellt dass es die grundlage
der sicherheit die es dann auch möglich
macht ganz unterschiedliche wege
national zu gehen die aber trotzdem
nicht für die anderen jeweils bedrohlich
kann man daraus schliessen hat scholz
wenn putin noch einmal die grenzen
verletzt und er hat das ja schon einmal
getan im stichwort ukraine und das
wirklich eine invasion gibt in diesem
land worauf er sich vorbereitet offenbar
im januar dann werden sie die
gaspipeline nord stream zwei nicht in
gang setzen das wäre eine ganz
dramatische regelverletzung die noch
ganz andere konsequenzen haben würde
aber jetzt ist doch unsere aufgabe erst
mal ganz klar zu beschreiben was wir
jetzt wollen und erreichen müssen
nämlich das genau so etwas nicht
passiert schon die
widerrechtliche inversion in der krim
oder auf der krim hat ja weit über die
krim hinaus
sorgen bei allen produziert ob das jetzt
immer so geht oder nicht und das ist der
punkt warum wir so sehr auf der
herrschaft des rechts und der
unverletzlichkeit der grenzen bestehen
müssen von wem wollen sie sich da eher
rat von angela merkel in sachen russland
oder von gerd schröder
ich habe jetzt das amt nicht mit vielen
zu beraten das werde ich sicher auch
immer tun aber welche politik verfolge
das kann ja jeder genau nachvollziehen
wir haben das gerade in diesem gespräch
entwickelt jetzt geht es also los herr
bundeskanzler
sie wollen das haben sie auch schon
gesagt in vier jahren wiedergewählt
werden ab jetzt zählt es ja wenn sie es
in einem satz sagen müssen wie würden
sie diesen anspruch an sich selbst jetzt
formulieren
klare kurs verfolgende ziele das ist
jetzt nicht nur literatur was wir da
produziert haben mit dem
koalitionsvertrag das muss alles schnell
gemacht werden insbesondere die
beschleunigung unserer fans genehmes
prozessen mit will vorankommen in diesem
land gute kooperation unter den partnern
ich wünsche mir dass alle auch trotz
allen politischen unterschieden die
parteien familien nun mal mit sich
bringen als partnerinnen und partner
zusammenarbeiten und dass man sich
wechselseitig stark macht und ich glaube
einen solchen stil der durchaus was
neues in deutschland wäre den können wir
gemeinsam prägen und dann können wir
auch gemeinsam zur nächsten wahl
antreten daran werden sie ab heute
gemessen das war was nun übrigens nach
zweig plus regeln das muss man auch noch
mal sagen vielen dank der bundeskanzler
vielen dank liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer für ihr interesse des aus
berlin
willkommen zurück beim zdf spezial in
vielerlei hinsicht ist dieser tag heute
ein besonderer ja auch ein historischer
er markiert den friedlichen übergang der
macht ein ganz wichtiges element in
einer demokratie wie ordnet sich dieser
tag ein karl hinterleitner über wege zur
macht und den umgang damit
es ist eine von vielen amtsübergabe
heute in berlin das wirtschafts und
energieministerium geht von peter
altmaier an robert habeck der sich
erkennbar in seine neue rolle erst noch
finden muss
das ist noch ungewohnt ich wusste jetzt
auch nicht wie es weitergeht aber da ich
jetzt herr minister bin sage ich danke
dass sie da waren die veranstaltung ist
geschlossen deutlich feierliche war die
stimmung im bundestag stunden zuvor der
neue kanzler beim ablegen des amtseids
ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft dem
wohle des deutschen volkes widmen seinen
nutzen mehren schaden von ihm wenden das
grundgesetz und die gesetze des bundes
wahren und verteidigen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde
am nachmittag dann die offizielle
übergabe im kanzleramt scholz und merkel
harmonisch ein reibungsloser
regierungswechsel beide mit lobenden
worten für einander sehr geehrter herr
bundeskanzler hieber olaf scholz sehr an
vielleicht dass es eine spannende
erfüllende aufgabe ist auch eine
fordernde aufgabe aber wenn man sie mit
freude an geht dann ist es vielleicht
auch eine der schönsten aufgaben die es
gibt das war eine große zeit in der sie
kanzlerin dieses landes waren und sie
haben auch großartiges bewegt es wirkte
rundum wie ein natürlicher übergang ja
fast so als wäre als nachfolger für
angela merkel überhaupt nie jemand
anderes vorstellbar gewesen als olaf
scholz
olaf scholz hatte das ganz große glück
dass am schluss der autoritäts profit
der kanzlerin also das gefühl sie kennen
mich dass diese autorität am stärksten
ob olaf scholz übertragen wurde das war
so ein gewinnerthema und er hatte von
anfang an diese hoffnung dass das
passieren könnte wenn der bevölkerung
bewusst wird merkel tritt ab dann trete
ich an ihre stelle ich mache die raute
und ich bin gewissermaßen merkel 2.0
diese rechnung ist aufgegangen
der stark für die ampel wird aber nicht
einfach denn die üblichen 100 tage
schonfrist hat diese regierung nicht
sind sofort ergebnisse gefragt
jetzt gilt das dass wir liefern als
ampel bis gilt dass das wir vertrauen
schaffen untereinander und in diesen
schwierigen zeiten in der mitte der
pandemie bei der großen klimakrise über
internationale unordnung bei der
zunehmenden spaltung dieser gesellschaft
tatsächlich auch befrieden lösungen
bringen und die leute das gefühl haben
dass wir anderen problemen arbeiten und
nicht für uns - selber beschäftigen der
neue kanzler hat einiges vor der brust
zum einen die regierungsarbeit dann den
zusammenhalt der ampel und an den linken
flügel in der eigenen partei der jetzt
schon klar macht dass man mit ihm
rechnen muss er weiß eben auch dass die
spd eine diskussionsfreudige partei ist
das wird sie auch bleiben da bringt auch
gar nichts und wenn irgendwer von uns
versucht die partei dazu disziplinieren
und ich bin auch fest davon überzeugt
regierungshandeln wird langfristig nicht
leichter wenn man seine partei sie die
rdx und dann gab es noch glückwünsche
vom verlierer auch armin laschet
gratulierte olaf scholz dem vierten
sozialdemokratischen kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland
und in berlin begrüße ich jetzt den
amtierenden vorsitzenden der cdu guten
abend herr laschet guten abend herr
fornoff sie sind ja für die union als
kanzlerkandidat ins rennen gegangen aber
nur als zweiter ins ziel gekommen wie
schwer fällt es ihnen heute den aufbruch
in eine andere richtung zu erleben
na ja wir haben ein wahljahr hinter uns
mit vielen auf und ups und natürlich
hätten wir diese wahl gerne gewonnen
aber das ist heute der demokratische
abschluss dieses prozesses es gibt eine
neue regierung es gibt einen neuen
koalitionsvertrag und es gibt seit heute
einen neuen bundeskanzler und ich finde
in einem solchen moment müssen wir auch
als land zeigen wie er solch
demokratischer wechsel gut funktioniert
regierungen gibt es überall auf der welt
aber eine opposition die aus der einen
rolle hinein wächst in eine andere die
gibt es nur in demokratien deshalb ist
auch die oppositionsrolle eine die die
cdu jetzt für sich annehmen will schauen
wir noch mal auf die neue regierung die
hat sich viel vorgenommen von der
energie bis zur digitalisierung von
wohnungsbau bis zur pandemie bekämpfung
wo hätten sie mit einer unionsgeführten
regierung andere akzente gesetzt ich
glaube viele dieser themen liegen auf
der hand sie haben eben in der sendung
was nun mit olaf scholz über die
internationale lage gesprochen die hätte
jede neue bundesregierung bewältigen
müssen da gibt es übrigens auch viel
übereinstimmung zwischen bundesregierung
und opposition
die klima wende die energiewende das
industrieland zu erhalten und trotzdem
die klimaziele zu erreichen
auch das war in der programmatik der
union mit dabei es geht jetzt um die
praktische umsetzung da wird man jetzt
als opposition genau sehen müssen wird
denn das alles eingehalten was da
versprochen wird und wenn sie mich
fragen wo gibt es im programm in dem
koalitionsvertrag unterschiede der
akzent der inneren sicherheit wäre
sicher in einer unionsgeführten
regierung stärker auch prononcierter
beschrieben worden das ist ein feld wo
sich eher fdp und grüne durchgesetzt
haben die cdu muss sich neu sortieren
personell passiert das mit der wahl
ihres nachfolgers im parteivorsitz aber
wir müssen sie sich inhaltlich neu
aufstellen um nicht dauerhaft opposition
zu bleiben ich finde wir müssen eine
kluge
oppositionspartei werden
opposition heißt nicht populismus
opposition heißt auch nicht
alles schlecht reden was die regierung
vor trägt sondern opposition heißt sie
an ihren maßstäben die sie sich selbst
gesetzt haben messen opposition heißt
dann im zweifel alternativen aufzuzeigen
und wir erleben ja jetzt bereits in der
korona pandemie das sicher drängendste
thema auch für die neue regierung die
wir als opposition bereits seit zwei
drei wochen denn im bundestag war ja die
mehrheit schon früher bei der ampel auch
als die alte regierung noch im amt war
welche akzente wird da anders gesetzt
hätten viele vorschläge sind
aufgegriffen worden die
ministerpräsidenten der länder haben
ebenfalls noch einmal deutlich gemacht
was jetzt zur pandemie bekämpfung
dringend gebraucht wird an
instrumentarien und wenn das
infektionsschutzgesetz dann in dieser
woche bereits geändert wird dann ist das
auch ein zugehen auf unsere
konstruktiven vorschläge die wir in den
letzten tagen gemacht haben also daran
können sie erkennen
man kann opposition mit konstruktiven
vorschlägen machen man kann sie auch
sehr klug machen und das ist unser ziel
und darüber hinaus werden wir in den
ländern und auch zeigen das cdu geführte
regierungen ebenfalls gute erfolge
erzielen können vielen dank für das
gespräch armin laschet bitteschön
1 hat die neue regierung sicher nicht
eine schonzeit um sich in ruhe an die
arbeit zu machen denn das virus kennt
keine pause die pandemie wird zur ersten
bewährungsprobe für die ampel die lage
ist ernst und mindestens mal regional
außer kontrolle wie im thüringischen
landkreis saalfeld rudolstadt wo die
sieben tage ins events auf knapp 2000
geklettert ist die intensivstation sind
voll es herrscht alarmstufe rot hanna
faist war vor ort
landkreis saalfeld-rudolstadt
zweithöchste instituts in thüringen
tendenz steigend trotzdem mahnwache ohne
maske von denen die das virus und seine
verbreitung für hysterie halten
massenpsychose die die tiere ich nicht
wie im hiesigen landratsamt unterdessen
notstand die bundeswehr auf neue mission
für diese vier soldaten heißt es für die
nächsten acht wochen headset statt
panzer sind am tag fast an die 300 neuen
fällen hier reinkommen müssen eine woche
aufholen und wieder tagesaktuell hier
sein zu können aber wirkliche kontakt
verfolgen wer an welchem tag mit dem zu
tun hat das geht gar nicht mehr 50
mitarbeiter konnte die kommune zusammen
ziehen sogar die örtliche badeanstalt
beteiligt sich und trotzdem kommen sie
kaum hinterher wir haben eine eine
völlig unkontrollierte durchseuchung im
landkreis amtsarzt stieler ist besorgt
denn besonders die ungeimpften kinder
und jugendlichen tragen das virus von
der schule nach hause und machen so das
infektionsgeschehen immer weiter an wir
haben da keinen plan dafür dass ist
übergriff wurde gruppe ist das ähnlich
die kinder halten alte mediziner spruch
ja die kinder erhalten das vierte gruppe
am laufen und die alpen verbringen der
spruch im landkreis bittere realität in
diesem altenheim starben in den
vergangenen tagen 28 bewohner die
mehrheit von ihnen war ungeimpft im
stellen sind rar auf dem land deshalb
wurde in rudolstadt aufgestockt 500
impfungen pro tag alle drei minuten zwei
spritzen termine auch kurzfristig
verfügbar und tatsächlich ein impf
neuling
post impfung ich sage im ort besser spät
als nie wie aber umgehen mit denen die
sich bisher nicht immunisieren lassen
wollen dieser bus unternehmer setzt auf
finanzielle anreize
120 euro für die vollständige
immunisierung mindestens 30 fahrer haben
sich seit dem impfen lassen waren es ja
viele junge mitarbeiter die sich einfach
keine gedanken drüber gemacht haben die
jetzt sauber zu hilfen gehen die
hartnäckigen corona leugner die haben
wir natürlich auch im unternehmen aber
die werden wir mit unserem aufwands
nicht dazu bringen sich impfen zu lassen
nicht impfen lassen rund 400
demonstranten sind es an diesem abend
ihr protest ist bisher friedlich aber
ein weiterer infektions treiber für
einen landkreis am limit
und im studio begrüße ich die
politikwissenschaftlerin andrea römmele
guten abend begraben wie sehr bestimmt
denn das corona wir haben gerade portale
gesehen den start der neuen regierung
total die neue regierung muss jetzt
liefern
sie hat keine schonfrist wie andere
regierungen denen man ja erst einmal die
berühmten 100 tage im amt gönnt das wird
diese regierung nicht haben sie muss
sofort in die puschen kommen wie man
sagt die vierte welle brechen das wird
jetzt von ihr gefordert und daran wird
sie auch gemessen werden die fdp als
kleinster koalitionspartner die hat sich
ja immer wieder gegen harte lockdown
maßnahmen und auch ausgangssperren
ausgesprochen droht da in der
ampelkoalition schon die erste
zerreißprobe davon gehe ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht aus die fdp wird jetzt auch
merken dass sie keine oppositionspartei
ist dass sie in der regierung mit zwei
weiteren koalitionspartnern angekommen
ist die lage hat sich ja auch dramatisch
geändert ändert sich auch täglich alle
koalitionspartner die fdp eingeschlossen
sind auch unter öffentlichem druck unter
druck der berater der virologen und so
weiter und die fdp hat ja auch schon zu
erkennen gegeben dass man gewisse
maßnahmen eben auch anpassen muss der
lage entsprechend jenseits der pandemie
ist das heute ja auch ein historischer
tag muss man sagen die ära merkel ist zu
ende nach 16 jahren was bleibt aus
dieser zeit frau merkel wird sicherlich
als die krisenkanzlerin in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen die
deutschland sehr erfolgreich durch große
krisen manövriert hat wir erinnern uns
an die finanzkrise an fukushima an den
flüchtlings sommer jetzt die große
corona krise da hat sie uns gut durch
meine friert sie war aber auch eine
kanzlerin die eher reaktiv regiert hat
als aktiv eine große vision einer großen
plan verfolgt hat die neue regierung die
will ja erklärtermaßen einen aufbruch in
ein moderneres deutschland organisieren
wo rechnen sie damit wandel und womit
kontinuität
kontinuität sicherlich in
aussenpolitischen themen auch wenn
annalena baerbock hier eigene akzente
was eine menschenrechts orientierte
außenpolitik anbelangt setzen wird aber
kontinuität auch in den bündnissen ganz
klar auch wandel große umbrüche was
klimaschutz anbelangt was
digitalisierung anbelangt und ganz große
veränderungen und einen großen schritt
nach vorwärts was
gesellschaftspolitische themen anbelangt
die wahl ab 16 neue deutschland soll hat
ein attraktives einwanderungsland werden
die streichung des paragrafen 219 also
die streichung des informations verbotes
für abtreibung all das sind neue
maßnahmen harmonie war ja bisher als bei
ungefähr die erste ampel pflicht wie
stabil kann dieses bündnis sein das doch
ziemlich gegensätzlich ist wenn man sich
zum beispiel die programme von fdp und
grünen an kommt die ampelkoalition
versteht sich als projekt und sie ist ja
auch im freien stücken zusammen gekommen
im gegensatz zur großen koalition die
wir hatten das war ja eine
notgemeinschaft wenn wir uns an 2017
2018 erinnern sie hat in der
sondierungsphase und in den
koalitionsverhandlungen vertrauen
zueinander entwickelt darauf gilt es
jetzt aufzubauen klar ist aber auch dass
es inhaltliche auseinandersetzungen
geben wird in der koalition aber auch im
bundestag wir müssen uns an eine
stärkere opposition wieder gewöhnen mehr
auseinandersetzung was letztendlich aber
auch das kernstück der demokratie ist
vielen dank für das gespräch frau remler
sehr gerne
das demokratische ritual des
machtwechsels ist vollzogen kanzler
ministerinnen und minister sind ernannt
es kann losgehen für die ampel
corona mitsamt der neuen variante
überlagert bis auf weiteres alles was im
koalitionsvertrag sonst an zielen fest
geschrieben wurde das sind unschöne
statt bedingungen der realitätscheck für
rot grün gelb der beginnt jetzt
das war unser zdf spezial vielen dank
für ihr interesse mehr informationen
jederzeit auf zdf heute.de und später
auch im heute-journal ihnen noch einen
schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]